[Música]
existen situaciones en la vida que
cuando las pensamos nos parecen
imposibles de pasar porque de pronto no
nos sentimos preparados no tenemos las
capacidades o porque son muy fuertes y
quizá emocionalmente no las podamos
afrontar yo no sé si ustedes tengan
clara esta situación pero yo sí que
tenía la mía
y esta era tal vez una de las creencias
más fuertes en mi vida
crecí como la mayoría de las personas
queriendo ser feliz y exitosa y que
quiere decir feliz exitosa
puedes hacer todo lo necesario para que
eso que yo me soñaba y me imaginaba
empezará a darse que todo saliera muy
bien y nada se saliera al formato así
que empecé por estudiar me gradué en
mercado de publicidad
empecé en mi vida profesional y se mi
especialización me casé tuve mis hijos
bueno pues una vida muy completa
pero era mucha la energía que yo usaba
en mantener todo bajo control no que
nada se salga que las cosas sean en los
tiempos que son con los hijos en el
trabajo con cada cosa como que todo
fuera funcionando sin que se me fuera a
salir de ese formato y eso empezó a
despertar en mí como una serie de
frustración y como de inseguridad de
miedo de impotencia
y yo sentía que era yo no sé si ustedes
han visto este cubo de rubik que a veces
tenemos que uno como que va armando por
un lado dice bueno ya me va quedando y
de pronto hay mira por el otro y no pero
como se descuadró todo por este otro
lado y empieza a sentir como que la vida
se fuera de un lado pero era muy difícil
que todo estuviera organizado como yo
quería para mí feliz y exitosa
así que bueno por las noches cuando yo
cerraba los ojos y le daba las gracias a
dios y dios y a diosito gracias por esta
vida tan completa tantas cosas lindas
que tengo en este momento yo me pronta
pero porque no me la estoy gozando tanto
porque me parece más estresante que de
disfrute era como una carrera detrás de
la felicidad
y bueno pero así va a ser siempre o sea
mañana otra vez la carrera el estrés las
cosas los problemas
cuanto más
y le preguntaba adiós esto es todo
bueno pues les quiero contar que la vida
me respondió
el 21 de noviembre del 2013 mi
cumpleaños número 36 la vida me dio un
regalo
me trajo un momento para brillar
y este regalo estaba muy mal envuelto se
veía horrible por fuera
pero este regalo ha hecho cosas
increíbles por mí cambió mi vida me
conecto conmigo
le dio sentido a todo me motivó me retó
me inspiró me ayudó a poner en su lugar
lo que realmente era importante
y me ha hecho sentir en cada poro de mi
piel el amor la unión y la fuerza de mi
familia de mis amigos y de todas las
personas que tenía cerca
este regalo venía con una tarjeta
cuando sacó la tarjeta al sobre el
regalo y leo decía
carcinoma ductal infiltrante
hormonodependiente estadio 3
no entendía nada pero para los humildes
cáncer de seno
esto no me puede estar pasando 36 años
sin antecedentes es una vida saludable
dos hijos todavía muy chiquitos y toda
una vida por delante son esos momentos
que uno dice esto lo que puede estar
pasando a mí eso le pasa a otra persona
pero a mí a qué horas y a qué hora se me
sale la vida del formato
con este papel en la mano y con este
diagnóstico
pues fue inevitable que viniera a mi
mente un momento de mi infancia cuando
acompañaba a mi mamá a sus prácticas de
enfermería y tal vez fue como ese primer
acercamiento con la enfermedad
y me acuerdo yo ay chiquita viendo estas
personas pues enfermas sufriendo con
dolor con cara de angustia con un estrés
muy grande y yo fui no esto es terrible
esta es mi situación invivible o sea yo
nunca quiero pasar por aquí me parece
imposible de vivir bueno pero ahí estaba
ahí estaba con esta situación
y obvio llegaron mis miedos mil
preguntas en todo este momento
que en ese momento no sabía cómo
responder pero tal vez la primera
pregunta que me respondí es cómo voy a
vivir esta si es mi situación más
difícil
y tal vez ese impacto tan fuerte que
tuve de mi infancia me hizo saber que
esto no podía ser una tragedia en mi
vida y tenía que convertirse en un reto
así que le pedí a mi esposo ya las
personas más cercanas que me acompañaran
de una manera diferente
y que me acompañan de las diferentes
porque cuando estamos viviendo un drama
y nos acercamos a acompañar a alguien
con un drama pues la energía es pobre
que angustia pero cuando tenemos una
situación en la que creemos que la otra
persona lo va a lograr y que es un reto
pues es muy distinto pues ellos
aceptaron creyeron en mí me dieron todas
esas fuerzas
y con este papel en la mano
yo miraba y decía bueno ya voy a vivirlo
como un reto en mi vida pero saben que
es que esto no era lo peor
dos semanas atrás a este diagnóstico me
había enterado
que estaba embarazada tenía 13 semanas
de embarazo de mi tercer hijo que venía
en camino
como es posible que uno por un lado esté
creando vida y por otro lado le diga no
es posible que su vida vaya a terminar y
que esté en riesgo pues de perderla qué
contraste tan fuerte
obviamente en todo este proceso los
médicos con este diagnóstico me dijeron
tiene 48 horas para decidir qué hacer
con su embarazo
tiene un tumor hormonodependiente
cuando crezca esto al final del embarazo
produciendo esa cantidad de hormonas no
se lo podemos decir hay que hacerles ya
cantidades de exámenes para saber si
tiene en otra parte de su cuerpo
resonancias mamografías radiografías
exámenes que pueden poner en riesgo la
vida de su bebé
y pues es inevitable la quimioterapia y
hay que empezarla cuanto antes ya lo
tienen los ganglios y no tenemos tiempo
para esperar
si usted decide continuar el embarazo
pues no sabemos si no podemos garantizar
nada ni por usted ni por su bebé
si usted lo suspende arrancamos con un
tratamiento muy agresivo y seguimos para
adelante
les puedo decir con toda seguridad que
esta ha sido la decisión más difícil de
toda mi vida
y el momento que más lágrimas me ha
sacado es toda mi existencia
mi esposo diego
muy amoroso generoso y pendiente me dijo
lo que usted diga va a estar perfecto yo
la voy a apoyar y nos vamos para
adelante con su decisión
los médicos te apoyamos en tu decisión
pues vamos a hacer todo lo posible por
que esto salga bien pero lo que tú
decidas ahí estaremos bueno y el resto
de personas entre la familia y toda la
cantidad de personas que salí a
preguntarle por qué salí a preguntarle
al mundo entero usted qué haría pero
usted que haría que me aconseja uno
siempre espera que haya alguien que le
diga no vete por aquí no porque esas
decisiones pues quién va a tener la
responsabilidad y si esto sale mal
y eso estaba pasando un poco dentro de
mí por un lado las personas que me
decían no te pongas en riesgo pero por
otras mes ya oye tu corazón
y justamente sentía mi mente
a 2000 no te pongas en riesgo sacando
todo lo que saca en la mente no razones
esto por aquí sino que cuáles serían los
riesgos cómo sería pero por el otro lado
el corazón decía sigue adelante sigue
adelante sigue adelante
y hay ocasiones en que yo creo que
pensamos mucho y se nos olvida sentir
y en encrucijadas como estas la primera
que sale a la luz es la intuición esa
voz sabia el corazón
qué nos dice pero muchas veces no la
oímos
y estoy segura que muchas veces la mente
se confunde pero el corazón el corazón
siempre sabe la última conversación que
tuve en esta tanda de visitas fue con mi
ginecólogo
y cuando le digo bueno qué hacer me dice
porque vas a tomar esa decisión en este
momento suficiente con lo que te está
pasando ya hoy para que te pongas a
decidir sobre su embarazo tu bebé está
perfecto en este momento no le está
pasando nada
mira si quieres puedes venir a mi
consultorio todos los días y yo te voy a
cuidar y te voy a revisar y voy a estar
a tu lado
y si en algún momento vemos que está en
riesgo algo de tu bebé ese día tomamos
la decisión y con estas palabras con el
apoyo todo en familia y con ese
sentimiento tan grande en mi corazón
decidí empezar todo este proceso
seguimos con el embarazo
obviamente llega lo primero casi que a
la semana después de hacerme todos los
exámenes y estar súper pendiente que
nada le fuera pasar a mi bebé
llega a la primera quimioterapia
como les decía quimioterapia otra vez
piel de gallina
terrible de sufrimiento dolor eso es un
veneno va a acabar contigo te va a matar
todas las células
obviamente super angustia de no saber
cómo en qué caja negra me va a meter no
sabía que me iba a pasar y recuerdo ese
día que íbamos en el carro con mi mamá y
mi marido y episodio en este silencio yo
me preguntaba mentalmente a chivas te
estoy viviendo esto sea parece un sueño
cómo es posible que esté acá
pero bueno si ya voy a la quimioterapia
y empiezo a darme cuenta que menos mal
existen o qué tal este medicamento no
existiera pues estaría lejísimos de la
solución
la ciencia y los médicos son muy pelos
en esto y ya lo tienen claro bueno el
primer punto pero además estoy a minutos
de tomar la primera quimioterapia qué
tal esto empezará a demorarse más y más
y más si no lo tuviera ya y empecé a
darme cuenta que estaba camino a la
solución
obvio llegué al centro de oncología
cuando conozco las bolsas de
quimioterapia pues las enfermeras se
rieron porque las abrace mejor dicho de
verdad con un amor y con un
agradecimiento y fue de allí en adelante
mi ritual a la quimioterapia donde bueno
vamos a trabajar en equipo me van a
ayudar pilas con mi bebé vamos a salir
adelante con esto y de ahí en adelante
fue obviamente todo el proceso eso sí
antes de cualquier cosa que me pusieran
entonces por favor es que me la bolsita
yo le hablaba la bolsita todas las
instrucciones y se cargaba con la mejor
energía y eso logró que la misma
situación que me producía terror
cambiando el significado
me quitara todo mi miedo y sacará de mí
la mayor fuerza
fíjense a veces como las cosas pueden
ampliar los límites y cambiarse de
perspectiva simplemente si encontramos
que hay un poquito más allá
empezamos la quimioterapia
y llegó lo inevitable el pelo que parece
superficial obvio y ya me han dicho
algunas como habla de eso que super
superficial pero el pelo pues primero yo
pensé que iba a ser yo no sé por qué la
primera mujer que no se le iba a caer el
pelo llegué no estoy en el oporto
chiquitico le quitó peso va a quedar
regias en el pelo no se me va a caer
pues pues no fue tan así y el pelo fue
capaz de hacerme reír llorar
a veces nos identificamos mucho de cómo
nos vemos entonces tengo que estar bien
arreglarme entonces es que eres alta
bajita gordita flaquita el pelo largo y
si era un era un como un símbolo
importante para mí y seguramente para
las mujeres no como el símbolo de la
vanidad y cuando nos dicen que nos va a
cambiar algo en el cuerpo pues muy seno
y ahora como me van a ver y como la
gente va a entender esto y que van a
pensar cómo me voy a ver enferma que va
a ser todo esto pues claro todo eso pasó
por mí y al otro día el diagnóstico yo
había salido a comprar mi peluca con
esta peluca en la mano pues yo me la
puse tratando de mantener todo bajo
control así que nada se notará y dije
bueno yo llego a mi oficina y seguro
nadie lo nota voy a estar con mi pelo
vaya región pues resulta que el pelo se
paraba una punta que se leen coca vaca
iba a la peluquería le cortaban le
hacían de todo y siempre que diego mi
esposo me frontado y la peluca yo no
está en la peluquería le están
arreglando el pelo pues porque nunca
estaba bien para como yo me veía
la peluca se convirtió en motivo de risa
porque la gente me abrazaba y se
emocionaba y catalina se pensaba mucho y
obviamente después de cada brazo en todo
esto imagínense donde podía quedar la
peluca salía yo con una peluca si toda
movida y la gente obviamente pues se
moría la risa nos montamos al carro
bajaba en la ventana y la peluca salía a
volar mi marido de mis hijos a las
carcajadas y la peluca y la peluca y
finalmente un día salí con mi hijo
martín y resulta que estábamos en un
supermercado y entonces mientras
pasábamos el mercado martín en el
carrito la señora de la caja estaba ahí
y martín le dice a la señora señora sabe
que mi mamá no tiene pelo eso es una
peluca mamá quítate la peluca mamá la
peluca la gente de la fila de atrás la
señora de la caja yo bueno hice esto por
dios obviamente siempre acabo en risas
una vez más entendía
que algo que para mí era tan difícil o
que por lo menos pensaba que era muy
difícil de experimentar había ampliado
mis límites y me había llevado más allá
dejé la peluca arme mis pañoletas y
seguí con todo el proceso
me hicieron seis quimioterapias
embarazadas
cada quimioterapia envolvía alicia en su
bolsita de luz nada te va a pasar una
conexión super fuerte ella me daba toda
su fuerza yo le daba toda mi fuerza nos
necesitábamos en este proceso y como
digo siempre pues había dos corazones
allá latiendo para que todo esto saliera
adelante
y creo que este es un ejemplo bueno para
hablar de esto que hoy nos reúne y es
ver cómo el mundo se construye en
simultánea 'alicia crecía y yo crecía
junto a ella en todo lo que estábamos
viviendo pero adicional a eso en todo
esto que les estoy contando había un
detrás de cámaras que ustedes no se
pueden imaginar tenía un despliegue en
mi equipo de apoyo en mi familia en mi
esposo en mis hijos mis papás mi hermana
mi familia mis amigas las personas más
importantes de mi vida estaban ahí
dándome eso 100% acompañándome creciendo
conmigo enseñando y muchas veces
pensamos que no yo puedo solo soy yo soy
un duro mejor dicho voy a hacerme el que
no hoy es que esto tranquilos pero
mentiras que es muy lindo cuando no se
da cuenta que uno tiene algo que
aprender de los demás así como martín
enseñó con la peluca que hay que reírnos
de esto cada una de las personas que
estaban junto a mí me enseñaban algo
diferente y todas eran un regalito para
mí así que con este equipo de apoyo y
con todas las personas pues logré llegar
a mi primera victoria
semana 34 y nace mi alicia
llegó perfecta fuerte ver chiquitita
pero es súper bien llegamos al otro lado
obviamente hasta acabado y ha sido un
proceso fuerte había pasado por el
embarazo el parto el postparto la
quimioterapia bueno y estaba ahí cinco
días más adelante recibiendo mínima
quimioterapia tal cual me hayan dicho
los médicos no me estaban mejorados y
había que ser un tratamiento muy fuerte
para seguir y lograr recuperar ese
tiempo que habíamos tenido así que pasé
casi un año largo más en todo este
proceso me hicieron alrededor de 30
quimioterapias más una mastectomía
radical radioterapia fue un tratamiento
físicamente muy intenso
y yo con toda la ilusión de esperar
menos ya vamos para adelante si vamos
por la meta la siguiente victoria cuando
me digan que ya todo va a estar bien
pues llegó ese día y llegó el día en que
me dijeron
catalina estamos al otro lado ya
entonces está bien lista para salir a la
vida
y este es el momento que estaba sonando
con mayor ilusión lista para salir a la
vida no me van a creer entré en pánico
total de salir a la vida
y si esto me vuelve a pasar
de que tenía el control de cuál iba a
ser mi feliz y exitosa si es que la vida
cambia en un minuto y no nos damos
cuenta cómo era posible que la vida me
diera una segunda oportunidad y yo
estaba ahí muerta del pánico
bueno pues creo que ya sabía que era
inútil tratar de seguir acomodando todo
a mi forma porque la vida tiene su
propio formato y hoy creo que no se
equivoca lo que pasa es que todavía
nosotros no estamos muy convencidos así
que entendí que bueno la vida es como el
colegio porque aquí vinimos a aprender
lo que pasa es que tiene una pedagogía
muy distinta en el colegio a nosotros
nos dicen bueno aquí tienes tu lección
estudiante y yo mañana te hago la prueba
listo pero la vida nos dice ven aquí
está tu prueba y sabes que mañana me
dices y aprendiste la lección y era
momento de aprender mi lección era
momento de aprender mi lección de que
había pasado con todo esto
que era lo que más miedo me daba vivir
morir me estaba tratando inútilmente
como les digo de mantener que ese
momento fuera estático que no cambiará
ni la salud ni el orden ni nada y no
había entendido que la vida es
impermanencia que todo cambia todos los
días
así que bueno pues dije sí si me muero
me muero mañana en los meses en 10 en 5
en 90 años pues claro sufriría mucho de
no estar con mis hijos con mi esposo con
mi familia pero no puedo vivir hoy lo
que va a pasar con mis hijos cuando
tenga alicia 18 años no entonces y bueno
y quisiera obviamente cumplir mis sueños
y muchas cosas pero no puedo hacer nada
que quisiera que pasen diez años sino lo
que pasa hoy hoy lo que tengo es lo
único que tengo para disfrutar y si
tengo este día pues y si hoy día se
acaba y vuelven y tocan la campanita y
te volverás amenazado por convivencia y
te vamos a sacar del juego pues que ese
día diga jugué al 100% me jugué todas
las fichas y me las 12 y no me quedé con
esos pendientes por hacer y ese se
volvió un propósito en mi vida
ese feliz que tanto buscaba en llegar a
un momento que me trajera la felicidad
entendí que era empezar a disfrutar cada
segundo y empezar a superar todo eso que
me traía intranquilidad era ese
aprendizaje y el exitosa pues ya tal vez
no era tanto el reconocimiento sino
cuánto había aprendido de cada
experiencia así que ese feliz y exitosa
lo cambie por disfrute y aprendizaje
quiero compartirles un pequeño vídeo que
cuenta un poquito más de lo que fue esta
historia
[Música]
hoy es 5 de diciembre de 2013 es la
primera quimioterapia de catalina para
su cáncer de pechuga no es todo lo que
toca hacer para que se mejore
[Música]
hoy es abril 16 estamos en la clínica
santa fe está catalina de colmar a
paulina alicia ya está por salir
mientras que invite organizas para poder
salir por la parte de tu mamá todo está
bien que mamá está tranquila está
contenta de quitarte y saludarte
[Música]
he usado abril 19 acaba de llegar alicia
de la clínica en que a su casita para
estar con papá y mamá con sus hermanos
[Música]
eleva la papa
hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
les presento a martín y alicia
y bueno la vida cambia cada segundo pero
yo hoy estoy segura que todos tenemos
todos los recursos necesarios para pasar
cualquier experiencia de la vida y hoy
más que desearle a cada uno de ustedes
que le llegue lo mejor quiero invitarlos
y desearles que conviertan en lo mejor
cada cosa que les dije muchas gracias